et quand on a vu tous ces tweets on
était téléspectateur lambda lambda comme
de chez eux se sont dit ah ouais on est
on est on est déçu on est triste parce
qu'on aimait jeune homme on s'attache à
lui ont trouvé qu'il a un énorme talent
et ça a déçu énormément de monde qu'est
ce que vous avez à leur dire ce soir
moi je m'excuse déjà je tiens à dire à
tout le monde ce que les personnes qu'on
complète aux français ce que je couche
pour compte a carrément bas je m'excuse
je vais passer c'est une connerie vous
avez voulu faire le malin à l'époque moi
j'étais sûr j'étais sur internet avec
des potes on rigolait et c'est du lourd
c'est d'humour nul cdu seconde troisième
dixième degré c'est nul quoiqu'en baisse
et structures à moyen terme d'accor
services a déjà je me rappelais même pas
les armes postés et j'ai vu ça j'ai
presque td il ya plein de gens qui sont
sentis jamais mais blessé l'édition
senti visé pour ça que je voulais venir
ce soir ici c'est pour m'excuser et
surtout pour faire comprendre aux gens
que je suis pas raciste homophobe
pédophiles misogynie il ya toute la
tournée il ya même des médias compris
par je suis rien de tout ça je suis un
tout ça et c'est pour ça que c'est une
histoire
alors gilles verdez qui est vérité assez
virulent avec we believe i qu'est-ce que
vous avez lui dire ce que soient les
tweets pour moi même vous avez dit quand
conneries d'ados ou vannes déplacer pour
moi c'est pas acceptable c'est trop
choquant mais moi j'ai une question à
vous poser une chanson polémique très
polémique d'orelsan que la production
vous incite à chanter des tweets dont on
sait qu'ils existent vous vous souvenez
plus mais on sait qu'ils existent
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir été entre guillemets de jeter en
pâture par la production de the voice à
un audit au rac vous ne pouvez plus
maîtrisé après je pense pas je pense pas
parce que la prod nous dit bien faites
attention à vos tweets tout ça est lent
mais ça fait depuis 2013 regardez là là
je vais là je vais répondre à des
mobiles
il aurait dû regarder avant que ça c'est
sûr et certain mais c'est pas la
production qui a écrit les tweets de vie
donc voilà après il aurait dû vérifier
avant ça c'est sûr et certain
mais c'est lui le seul responsable de
ces tweets et ce qui dit il et c'est pas
la production qu'il appelait ya trois
ans qui tu vas faire de bord dont trois
ans tu vas faire des tweets éliminant
lorient une objection
non non mais moi je vous dire je suis
pas soucié devions j'aimerais avoir ce
soir le sentiment de vie parce que je
vis je vois sur les réseaux sociaux
tous ont dit ces tweets sont immondes
c'est inadmissible
est ce qu'on doit est ce que vous les
deux qui m non c'est pas les 3 à 20
milliards 4 c nicolas pernikoff vous
vous dites quoi de ça au fait moi je
m'excuse parce que j'ai été très
virulent il ya quinze jours trois
semaines et un moment donné c'est
l'histoire la frontière de l'ain team
s'était il faut remettre dans le
contexte au moment où ça a été fait
puisque j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches
s'était fait à un moment où il avait
très peu de copains dans son réseau
social et c'est une connerie de jeunesse
père que moi j'ai un gamin de 17 ans est
une vraie connerie de jeunesse et ce
qu'ils méritent la double peine c'est la
question parce que le mec a un talent
mais monstrueux mémé déverser 20 talent
montréal on la met à casser
il a la main tellement de personnes lui
permet d'accord d'accord il s'est
platement excusé
il vient de sortir grandir où il fait
une chanson pour s'excuser avec des mots
mais très juste
est ce que à un moment donné un môme de
17 ans mérite la double peine je veux
dire il le dit lui même il n'est pas
raciste il n'est pas homophobe il a
honte de ce qu'il a fait ou les quoi qui
se met par terre et qui vous supplie de
le laisser faire son métier
quand un mec a du talent comme ça il
faut savoir de tan tan pardonner et
pourtant il ya quinze jours j'étais
comme gilles verdez j'étais beaucoup
jouer se joue ensuite voulu après j'ai
été beaucoup trop sur medal aussi alors
on aurait dû pardonnez pas oui bien sûr
mais là aussi on aurait pu pardonner
l'autobus y aura ce qu'on l'a brisé 150
fois c'est toujours les de l'histoire
c'est où nous menons ya plus de nuances
on peut plus discuter même le plus
échangé on peut plus se justifier donc à
un moment donné oui un peu de nuance
il faut écouter les gens et puis essayer
d'avancer avec son temps moi j'ai été
aussi très dur avec 2010 est vrai que ce
qui est terrible histoire c'est que
c'était un vrai choix c'était une vraie
posture de prendre cette chanson qui est
totalement annulée par l'étude parce que
du coup ça avait une résonance terrible
à la chanson du band mekla en fait il
est il est comme un non mais c'est jeudi
passé ça a été en fait
voilà c'est une réaction et je trouve ça
dommage après moi j'ai été très dur sur
ménage dit effectivement il fallait
faire une sanction et je pense que tf1
ne pouvait pas ne pas sanctionner très
honnêtement après c'est vrai que c'est
un gâchis et je fais effectivement
maintenant a pas non plus il faut qu'il
faut qu'ils avancent mais en même temps
voilà mais c'est vrai que la résonance
des deux était très difficile à entendre
voilà ce que je pense alors on va passer
à la dernière partie de l'émission et je
vis
vous avez été virés donc de the voice
puisque tf1 n'a pas souhaité
s'embarrasser d'une polémique comment ça
s'est passé
c'est la production qui vous après ils
m'ont appelé ils m'ont appelé le
lendemain que ça tourne ça va tourner le
dimanche soir
d'accord le lundi matin vous avez tué
lundi matin on m'a appelé deux qui l'a
produit de la prod qui voit là bravo de
la preuve qui me dit ah bon tu t'en
doutes c'est terminé c'est terminé entre
nous et je comprends le choix je vous
avez vous été comprend le choix aller
pleurer vous avez mangé pas pleurer
parce que je m'étais fait à l'idée de le
dimanche soir que mais ces tweets vous
saviez qu'ils allaient sortir un moment
ou pas mais je savais même pas qu'ils
avaient posté non mais carrément je les
aurai supprimés